sie noch mal die augen davor nicht viel
[Musik]
wie weihnachten
herzlich willkommen zurück sagen wir
leute ich mich und genossen zentrale
zurück denn unsere liebste freundin
unser größtes youtube vorbild in unsere
allerliebste patientin die
möglicherweise ein kleines bisschen
unter verfolgungswahn leidet hat ein
neues video hochgeladen ihr müsst am
besten bescheid wie sich leute die
weihnachtszeit die adventszeit begonnen
und so manche youtuber der sich
möglicherweise seit einigen monaten
nicht gemeldet hat meldet sich wieder
zurückging muss man allerdings sagen
habe die ganze zeit relativ regelmäßig
und beladen hat aber in letzter zeit ein
bisschen unterlassen und zwar dass das
sprechen mit fiktiven charakteren
das ist jetzt zurückgekehrt denn bp
extra hat ein video namens rufen niemals
am ersten advent den elfern das schelf
an hochgeladen und ich als neutraler
youtube zuschauer fragt mich natürlich
was hat es mit diesem video auf sich ich
würde sagen wir schon mal 1 2 930 leute
wach werde jetzt wahrscheinlich schon
anhand des titels erraten haben
der erste dezember schon ja okay also
dass du die ausgangslage und bekkering
darf ja scheinbar mit dem game master
machen also von mir aus gerne aber sie
hat sich das selbst auferlegte hat sich
selbst gesagt okay ab jetzt kommen keine
game master videos mehr der game master
wurde irgendwie besiegt oder so hat sie
gesagt logische konsequenz was kommt
danach
natürlich 11 unter tel
dieses ist stets ein bouquet erster
dezember offiziell
ich werde dich umsonst macht geblieben
sei ja ihr wollt so gerne dass ich den
ich habe mich für das bei rebecca so
aussieht meint ihr die bleibt abends
einfach so länger wach und ziemlich weiß
gar nicht warum sie wach bleiben das ist
12 wo sie kann ich einschlafen 1 uhr
zwei fuhr
und so ist es auf einmal 3 uhr und sie
technisch so tack ich muss irgend
jemanden anrufen es ist 3 und nachts was
ist game master nähe von kiel scheiß
drauf den elfen schnell von ihr wollte
so gerne dass ich den 11freunde chef
wieder anrufe diese verfluchte nummer
die ich ja mal im internet gefunden
haben und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
was ich sagen soll wenn ich da anrufer
ist alles wie gehabt leute wir haben
wieder eine verfluchte nummer am start
selbstverständlich also ihr wisst ihr
bescheid wenn ihr schon das ein oder
andere video gesehen habe wo ich auf
videos von wickie reagiere das baby
schon ab und zu mal ganz gute
verbindungen zu gewissen internetseiten
hat wo man scheinbar verfluchte nummern
bekommt ich persönlich habe von dem
bisher nichts gehört aber die chance zu
geben
und ja auf einer dieser seiten hat biggi
dann die verfluchte nummer formell von
der chef gefunden und beruft jetzt an
und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was
ich sagen soll wenn ich dann rufe ich
muss eigentlich bücher wirklich die
dedication mit der rebecca so eine story
um diesen von der shell warum ich bin
scheinbar sie jetzt auf der liste der
bösen kinder weil sie im sommer
angerufen hat also ich meine die videos
heißt ja alle immer rufen niemals dann
und dann den und den an dem titel steht
rufen niemals am ersten advent in elf
und das schnell fahren aber scheinbar
darf man den nicht nur am advent nicht
anrufen sondern auch nicht im sommer
gerade nicht im sommer okay da denen ich
urlaub wisst ihr wie es ist wie
weihnachten oder eltern geschäft zu sein
das ist okay und dann über den ganzen
sommer über frei haben und was passiert
ja ich weiß aber nicht ob ich irgendwie
gleich damit anfangen soll zu sagen habe
hier rebecca ich weiß nicht ob das so
eine gute idee ist vielleicht sollte ich
lieber meinen namen nicht nennen aber
eigentlich kennt auch meine stimme
naja vielleicht ist jetzt nicht mehr der
selbe elf alles gefällt mir bei diesen
videos immer auch leute also es ist
immer so ein kleiner widerspruch
zwischen titel und tatsächlich ein video
inhalt also das video heißt ja jetzt
auch wofür niemals am ersten advent den
elf und der frage was macht ihr in dem
video ruft am ersten advent den helfern
geschäft warum das ist so als wenn da
gehört ein video machen so jo kinder ihr
dürft auf gar keinen fall am steuer
trinken macht es aber wer im auto sitzt
und dabei eine cola wodka säuft aber
machen uns mal ans eingemachte leute ich
spreche jetzt mal zu dem punkt wo sie
tatsächlich mit dem 11 telefoniert wir
sagen weil dieses videos die ich mache
ich irgendwo ist es auch lustig irgendwo
es auch geil was rebecca macht sondern
dass sie wirklich also ich weiß ja wie
gesagt immer noch nicht ob sie das
wirklich ein paar nachts aufnimmt oder
ob sie einfach rein die uhr vorstellt
das kann natürlich nicht sagen von hier
aus aber dass sie wirklich halt einfach
kann so ein freund oder eine freundin
und er sagt ja ich kann ich kurz als 11
und der chef im telefonbuch abspeichern
das für so ein video und wenn ich gleich
anrufer kannst du kannst du
weihnachtsmusik laufen lassen
[Musik]
müller stellt hier wird wieder aufgelegt
aber man muss auch verstehen es ist als
1111 nicht leicht
also man keine ahnung man es im klub man
trifft irgend jemanden trifft can't let
irgendwohin kennen gibt es so die
handynummer weil man muss jetzt gefragt
wer hat dann war es irgendwann wird die
elfen auf einen sauer und veröffentlicht
die eigene verfluchte handynummer im
internet danke 11 in jetzt ruft mich ein
bäcker weniger also zeit an
nochmals ich bin wieder in der
warteschleife
spielberg lässt nicht nach denn beck
hier also schon mal daran gedacht dass
der elf auch einfach seine privatsphäre
haben will so man auch mal ruhe haben
will vielleicht nicht die ganze zeit
angerufen werden von deutschen youtube
hallo ok also wenn wir jetzt ganz genau
hierhin hat dann kriegt man mit dass der
elf und des scheinbar deutsch spricht ok
kann man sich schon wundern da ich meine
111 und sl von micha 11 auf dem regal
also hat scheinbar in englischen namen
warum jetzt deutsch spricht leuchtet mir
nicht so ganz aber vielleicht ist es
soll nicht der sinn dieses videos dass
irgendwas einleuchten soll
im moment weiß dass ein 11 und call
center war das gerade angesagt wenn du
an weihnachten gut war es dann drücke
die 2 fakt ist die nummer von einem
helfen soll
rebecca aber der titel heißt nicht rufen
niemals am ersten advent das geschäft
callcenter ja also ich hab jetzt schon
erwartet dass du den elf selbst ein buch
das gerade 45 minuten einfach vorgespult
ist es immer noch das gleiche selber
frame selber kameraaufnahmen wissen was
ich meine rebecca besitzt immer noch da
mit ihrem handy hängt immer noch in der
leitung findet mal ein ende
david irgendwie stimmen nonsens runter
dem man kaum verstehen wieso das kann
man nicht mehr lachen kann man nicht
laut sagen
scheinbar streitet sie gerade mit dem
unterschied dass ich wirklich so
aussehen sie okay okay okay okay lass
uns das mal noch mal hat muss noch vor
augen
sie hat die läufer unter chef angerufen
verfluchte normale leute kein spaß ist
eine verfluchte nummer okay wenn jetzt
bei dem in der leitung und streitet sich
einfach mit dem darüber nein aber ich
hab dich doch letzten sommer angerufen
weil alle wollten das gerne wählen
2009 muss man an der stelle wirklich mal
sagen feier ist wissen wir dass auf mich
wirkt das wirkt so als wenn sie so ein
pärchen als wenn ich so ein pärchen dass
gerade so ein beziehungsstreit
wahrscheinlich sind die auch irgendwo
effektiven pärchen nicht mehr also wie
oft hat rebecca von 11 und 11 anrufen
ich meinen wünschen kleinen wunsch
[Musik]
nämlich comedy gauleiter ich muss mir
jetzt sagen dieses video rebecca liefert
in diesem video wirklich genau die
steuervorlagen legte sofort beim fußball
noch ein hermann dfs chef sagte selbst
leute es rufen dauert ungezogene kinder
in der leitung ein oliver kahn games
jetzt so ja das sind wirklich ungezogene
kinder die beim 11 und 11 anrufen weil
sie weihnachtsgeschenke haben wollten
ein backup diese ungesunde kinder von
denen hier die rede ist das sind die
weltweit versammelten youtuber die immer
noch den trend trend um diese
ausgedachte figur melken ok elf von
irgendwelchen kindern wie angerufen
haben irgendeine 13 jährige anna sobald
ich das richtig verstanden habe wollte
eine chanel tasche für 4000 euro haben
und bis heute
es ist wirklich das geld an dieser
ganzen sache ist sie einfach
vorzustellen und verstellt einfach
wirklich wieso ein echter gestresste
angestellte irgendwo in so einem
großraumbüro ist und einfach abgehakt
ist es wohl die ganze zeit irgendwelche
mängel anrufen
die 13 jährige anna die 4000 euro
schnell taschen wollte ja die kommt
wahrscheinlich über dein video zum 11
unterstelle callcenter leute wenn auch
ihr der meinung seid das tribeca ring
endlich den er von der chefin alle
anderen ausgedachten figuren in ruhe
lassen sollte dann schreib mir das gerne
in die kommentare decke drüber ich
vorgeschlagen dass wieder von oben kommt
in einen kanal ab
bleibt die leute und ruft natürlich
niemals am ersten advent infamous chef
an
ich bin raus macht's gut